someone told me you had dinner with
michael rappaport over the summer jd how
did it come about that you had dinner
with michael rappaport the famous actor
he was in my area doing a comedy show so
we met up who pays for dinner i assume
him uh he no we we sort of it was like a
dutch thing he might have actually he
just threw in some cash because he had
to leave before uh he went dutch with
you were you it was just the two of you
well it was my wife too but uh yeah we
all had it was fine i think a gut
rappaport picks up the tab no yeah i
don't think you let jd pick it up do you
isn't he on a tv show
sure but he came out here i i had no i
i'm not doing terribly i can pay for
myself no i know i know what you're paid
uh believe me i know
he should have paid for you oh stop it
that's fine did you do something silly
like order like an 800 bottle of wine or
something no no no no
i don't even think we ordered a bottle
of wine i mean
a little shocked here what i'm hearing
oh well howard what do you what he's not
telling you is that i had an appetizer i
had some fried calamari and i had to
leave early but before i left i offered
to pay the entire bill he tried to big
shot it in front of his beautiful
charming loving wife
so what i did is i left eighty dollars
for my calamari and my arnold palmer
okay
excuse me a very generous
michael michael left
eighty dollars jd for the free only had
was calamari
he ordered a meal i forget what it was
it was some it was like something i
think it was the right uh something with
the rice or whatever the risotto or
something i think yeah maybe it was
risotto but i left and i offered to pay
for the whole thing he was trying to big
shot me
don't worry i'm off for the summer
you understand i'm being a gentleman all
right be careful out there michael when
you're doing these shows i'm being
careful but before i leave i just want
to know what
gorilla truth baba bowie
did and added to the show this summer
while everybody else on the staff was
working that's my question can i just
say something because i know michael's
always looking to pick a fight and so i
want to say you know we did our fantasy
football draft last week so we did it
over zoom right right michael gets on
there he's got a plate of asparagus he's
practically shoving it up his nose like
he's eating like a disgusting pig
knots he's got bad skin whatever's going
on there just
like i come
cord jd
was he was jd backing up on this
electric jd
yes this is the microwave was doing
exactly this the whole time oh look at
that gorilla oh i'm like
stop eating we don't want to hear you
eat was like the whole i turned my
camera off i turned my camera off to be
nice i watched him eat for a half day
he's the grossest thing ever he was
eating
and you know what you were smart to turn
it off because you were eating because
no one wants to watch it dude we all
have to watch your
you were sticking kicking bones down
your mouth gary i also understand you're
upset that you were added to a uh
text chain oh michael rapper oh we all
were
so so the fantasy football thing is
right
hold on let me hear what you're saying
michael let me hear what gary has to say
about this what is this text change
you're talking about
holy sh
michael i know it's hard wait one second
so there's ten people in fantasy
football so somebody started a text
group last night i didn't start it most
of us didn't start it all of a sudden my
phone was like ding ding ding oh hey and
it's just a bunch of [ __ ] talking but
it's it's all rappaport all rapport all
the time you would think the guy doesn't
have a job the way he talks just like he
has nothing to do but that well sunday
we're watching fantasy football it's the
camaraderie everybody was talking about
he doesn't realize like it's 6 30 like
we're trying to unwind to go to bed the
next day he's just up till [ __ ]
whenever you think
unwind from scotch tasting what
unwinding what unwinding i have to
unwind from you
you